all right everyone we're I'm we're
really struggling here this is not easy
so can I ask everyone to put their pens
down and I want you to look up with me
as I try to work out and reveal an
answer for you okay now this is really
sneaky
because some of you have asked me like
which formula do I use and I like people
are throwing numbers at me and at this
point we're sort of getting it till I I
thought is it 18 is the seventh I don't
know I'm just gonna randomly throw
numbers that's a sign we're doing
understand the question so let me try
and unpack this for you hit pause I
really need all eyes up because I I need
you to think closely about this okay go
back to the original information we know
in the question how far apart are the
two more sorry I should say are the
first stop and the last not what's the
distance ten kilometers right ten
kilometers okay now let's just say let's
just say these are the only two stops
right so we've got n would equal in this
case M would equal one - there's two
stops right and then there's a ten
kilometer distance between them now we
know in fact the N is not - it's
something else but just stay with me
let's just suppose okay suppose there
were three stops this is two stops let's
just add one more stop in the middle
okay what would be the distance between
each of the stops it'd be five right
five five but hold on a second three
stops a lot of you are taking this
number ten kilometers and you're
dividing by the number of spots there
are but that does not give you five does
it right so what's going on what's going
on we're off by one in fact is that
sound familiar where does this
off-by-one come from it comes from the N
minus one in here right so how do we
actually fix this where whole I've got
ten kilometers right I'm dividing by n
minus 1 the N is the thing that I don't
know right
how many stops are there there are
actually 11 right now hold on a second
hold on is this actually equal Elevens
actually this number here isn't it isn't
that where it should be
now I'm highlighting this because one of
the reasons why you're all getting like
someone gave me like 99 or something
like with that copyright there are only
ten kilometers from end to end the
company 99 kilometers apart our problem
is we're not thinking carefully about
where our numbers go
that's not where 11 goes 11 goes here ok
that's a limit this is the common
difference that we're working out does
that make sense so the common difference
is 10 divided by 10 which is which of
course makes sense because look if I've
got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 stops h1 the
gap there are 11 stops and 10 gaps
between them the gap is what you're
actually interested in that's the one
kilometer does that make sense
now this is this is counterintuitive
it's counterintuitive because what we
want to do what we're confusing is the
number of gaps there are each of which
is Kalama the question was how far apart
are these stops what you were counting
was how many stops are there not you
were counting these things not these
things right how many these gaps are
there they're a 10 which is why you get
a difference of 1 you were close you
were close but but you are wrong in a
critical way so there's closer than this
yeah ok so what I'm gonna do is just
revisit this question one last time I
think what conversation we were having
at the front here with a few of us might
actually be very helpful for all of us
so I can ask you to laptops off but have
your books there and I'd love you to
ride along with me to see what's going
on ok
can I get your brain this be the last
thing we do and then the bill will go I
want to get your brain back in this
problem so what we did was just to
review we worked out that there were 11
stops
where the truck was going to drop its
gravel and then what we're trying to
work out was this distance between them
okay now some of you looked at min
you're like that's weird thinking about
gaps and there's always one less that is
confusing so I want to show you how you
can use this formula to actually get
this answer which requires a little bit
less like thinking but you still have to
interpret carefully here's where it's
gonna work we'll start with that formula
it says the sum of n terms that's the
whole journey but we're interested in
what was it by the way the truck
traveled how far 550 I believe it was
okay now that's the total journey we've
already worked out how many journeys it
takes over time it takes one journey for
every single one of the stops then it
takes so far so good so I'm gonna write
instead of and on - all right 11 on -
that's how many journeys it took n
equals 11 then I fill in the rest of it
now when I write in to a what am i
counting is one journey it's there and
then back the very first one a is I've
got to get to 20 and then back
so around journey is 40 so this is going
to be 80 that I'm gonna write in here so
far so good I already know I substitute
it in 111 minus 1 should be equal to
that's the N minus 1 so I'm gonna write
in 10
there are you okay with that - sure I
got 10 from it's 11 minus 1 and then
this is the question I was really asking
right what's the common difference the
gap between each of them okay now help
me out you guys what am I gonna get
multiply both sides by 2 gives me on the
left-hand side 1100 I've got an 11 here
and then this stuff so when I divide
both sides by 11 I get 100 thank you
John
okay this gives me 80 plus 10d so what's
my next step to try and isolate I'll
subtract 80 from both sides which gives
me 20
okay now I'm at my final step what do I
need to do to get the answer I divide by
10 which gives me 2 there's just one
teeny problem we know that's not the
answer right we already worked out
earlier that the gap is 1 so why do I
have to
aha yes what I've got is and you can see
it here on the board that's why I left
it there I've got a return journey back
and forth back and forth back and forth
so this D equals 2 is double what I
actually want I don't want the journey
back and then forth which is 2 I just
want the gap between two stars which is
1 exactly half of that so even when you
just use a formula and just throw the
numbers in you still have to be careful
and cautious with that final answer and
interpreter with great care